Let's imagine that, um, I'm the president or you're talking to the president.
I know you you've been, uh, advising the Biden campaign. Um, is that correct?
I advise Biden on deep fakes, uh, two years ago when they started.
Pretty, yeah, pretty recent vintage. Um,
what are the safeguards and countermeasures that we could install?
Because a lot of people listening to this right now and Nina are like,
Oh my gosh, like I give up, like,
I think I'm watching Andrew Yang talk to Nina shake, but maybe I'm not like,
you know, this whole thing could just be like a giant fabrication,
which it could be theoretically. Uh, how do we know? So,
so you do make some suggestions,
but we'd love to talk to you about what possible solutions look like.
What could we do if let's say hypothetically,
we have control of the government of the United States of America, 2021,
we look up and say, all right, we have to address this problem.
Broadly, the solutions kind of fall into two categories.
The first is the technical solutions.
So building the AI software to detect video
manipulations because as synthetic media.
Yeah. So let's start with that. Nina,
like let's say you're Russia and you make a hundred synthetic, uh,
media videos and audio recordings.
Do we have the technology right now that could go through and be like fake,
fake, fake, fake, fake, fake,
and then there's one real one in there and be like real.
So right. Um,
ish is the answer because there are several kind of deep
fake detection tools,
but given that they can be generated using different kind of, um,
machine learning systems,
there's no one detection tool that can detect them all.
And the other crazy thing about trying to build the detection tools is that
every time you think you've built a really cool piece of software,
AI software to detect all the fakes, um,
you're giving the person who's making the fakes a foot up.
So it's always going to be a cat and mouse game.
So there are some tools out there.
There is no one universal tool is the short answer.
Could you have a tool that gives you like a spectrum of
probability where you could say this thing is probably real,
this thing might be fake, uh, within like a certain measure of confidence.
I get that you can't categorically say real fake, but you could be like,
we think this one's probably real, or we think this one's probably fake.
Yeah. And, and that is how those detection tools work right now.
The ones that are already out there, they're like, Oh,
this is 90% probably synthetic. Um, but, uh,
I would say that because we're just at the start of this synthetic media
revolution,
like we haven't actually come to the stage yet where it's ubiquitous,
but in four years' time, when it is time for the next election,
some experts who I speak to think that as much as 90% of video content online
can be synthetic. So
there is an urgency which isn't,
so it hasn't hit us yet, but in four years' time,
we're looking at something completely different.
I actually think this election is more likely to be disrupted by
something called the Liar's dividend. If everything can be faked,
then everything can also be denied.
And that is something called a Liar's dividend.
And you already see that happening now.
And this is something that's only going to get more potent as time goes on.
There's actually one candidate,
a Republican sounded at standing for Congress who took the George Floyd video,
that powerful video, which unleashed a movement,
not only across the U S but across the world.
And she's written a 24 page documents saying that it's a deep fake,
so you're going to see a lot more of that.
Okay. So there, isn't an easy technical fix. Uh,
you can have some AI tools that catch some degree of,
uh, synthetic media or some proportion of it,
but not enough where you can say problem solved. So what else,
what else lies in the technical? Yeah.
So, so that the one, the first part of technical solutions is detection.
The second part is provenance, right?
So you actually try to prove what media is
authentic.
And this is going to become increasingly important for like activists,
journalists,
people who are trying to record something and hold
someone either to account as a kind of human rights abuse,
or to show that what they have done is authentic.
And you basically try and embed that into almost the hardware of your
phone or your camera. It's almost like a watermark, which is indelible.
You can't tamper it. So that always is shown to be authentic.
So those are the kinds of two technical solutions, detection and provenance,
but ultimately this isn't a PR this isn't a technology problem
in the sense that the technology here until, I mean, we have fully sentient AI,
which we don't the technology assistant amplifier of human intention.
So the real solution comes with policy
legal, uh, digital and digital literacy and education.
Um, this is something that just the technology isn't going to make go away.
It's something that society needs to grasp as a national
security. And I would say, you know,
one of the most important issues for the future of liberal democracy.
So we need people like you who understand how
technology is reshaping politics and society,
and then can communicate that to the public in a way that they understand
what's at stake here then only can I hope that there is kind of the
political and public will galvanized in order to make this, uh,
the priority, which I believe it needs to be,
because I think there's a short window in which something can still be done.
And otherwise the kind of vested powers that benefit from the
information ecosystem being the way that it is.
It becomes increasingly difficult to do anything about it.
So right now, in the United States,
we have deep skepticism of the media. I think the trust in media that,
um, I saw most recently, it was 41%, the major media organizations,
and it runs the gamut, uh, along party lines.
So if you are a Democrat in the United States of America,
you trust national media at a higher level, let's call it 58% or 60%.
And then independence are around 40%.
And then Republicans are at something like 20%. So, so that's, uh,
it's been migrating downward over time. So that's where we are right now.
So then if you go and say, look, we have to get our arms around this, uh,
and establish what the heck is real. And what's not real,
like what's true and false.
You have a significant proportion of the American people already that are like,
whatever you're doing. Like I don't trust it is nonsense. Like,
you know, you're, you're trying to control me, control us. And there's a very,
very deep heritage in the U S um, which I agree with,
uh, of freedom of the press, freedom of information,
like censorship is terrible.
And it seems like if you're trying to establish what's real or true,
then what you're really trying to do,
essentially the heck out of a bunch of people. So that's like the,
the current landscape. Um, and then you go to them and say, no, look,
this is a massive problem. Like,
you don't even know if I'm real right now because I got a video
screen. Uh,
so we would need to line up in my view, major media organizations,
major technology companies, uh, nonprofits and the government,
and get everyone together and say, all right, like,
let us try and establish some standards and rules of the road to say that, uh,
you have to use these devices. And if you don't use these devices, then, uh,
it will be marked as don't know if this is real, uh, you know, and,
and that can include our cell phones. So at least, you know,
if I take a cell phone video, it's attributed to me and like, you know,
so it's not like you necessarily need to have a giant camera from, um,
from CNN or wherever, but like there, there needs to be some, uh,
provenance to your point,
there needs to be some kind of chain of ownership of this.
And then someone like puts their name on it and says, yeah, I was there.
And that happened. Um, so that's,
the challenge is trying to bring that coalition together and then try and get
this trust in whatever standards you establish, um,
to rise over time.
If you look at other places where society-wide
mobilization to disinformation has been really effective, take, for example,
the small Baltic state of Estonia,
some 3 million they've often been in the eye of kind of Russian disinformation
campaigns.
And they really turned it around by basically adopting what you just pointed
out, which is a whole society wide mobilization,
where you have kind of industry working with policy makers,
working with citizens, working with NGOs,
but taking that network approach is really difficult. Um,
and I would say that if the current presidency continues in the
United States,
then that challenge becomes even more difficult because what's quite clear
is that the president has a vested interest in making sure that the information
ecosystem is corroded.
He is one of the biggest purveyors of disinformation.
And if this continues for another four years,
I find it difficult to see the way back for the United States.
No,
that's the argument that so many people are making is that we can't handle four
more years of Trump. I happen to agree with that.
I think that four more years of disintegration, uh,
will lead us to a point where it's very difficult to come back. Um,
though many people think of it for different reasons than what you're describing
Nina, but there have been folks who've said that U S democracy
itself is on the line.
Yeah. And I, I don't think that's an exaggeration at all, because if, I mean,
democracy can only work.
Liberal democracy can only work if you have some kind of objective
reality and some commitment to truth and the pursuit of truth.
If the pursuit of truth no longer matters than the only thing that matters is
power and who has the power to control narratives.
So that then ends up becoming very authoritarian.
Well, you know what? This is Nina. Like,
this is a problem that prevents us from solving other problems. Uh, and so that,
and so that, that's where my attention is focused right now is, um,
is we have to fix the machinery of democracy. Uh,
and at this point it's not enough to try and get the right people embedded into
the machine.
You have to try and fix the machine itself because right now this machine,
this machine is breaking down in a way that even if I stuck like a good person,
uh, in Congress, it's not going to save us.
Absolutely focus on the architecture of the machine.
I think we're absolutely on the same page here, Andrew.
Okay. I'm going to become the mechanic Nina, and I know you are too.
Thank you so much for edifying us.
Nina's book is deep fakes that coming in FACA lips, uh,
it's compelling. It's scary.
And hopefully we will do something about it together.
Thank you for listening in. I hope you enjoyed this conversation. If you did,
please do subscribe to yang,
speaks and click on notifications so we can let you know every time we have a
new episode.